che bello quando fai l'episodio 2 di uno
degli horror che è stato il più
d'impatto il peggiore mai fatto negli
ultimi dieci anni è una bella giornata
eravamo rimasti nelle fogne e ragazzi
che io ho deciso di interrompere
l'episodio in un momento effettivamente
dove potevo permettermelo scegliere
ovviamente perché che fa in uno stop in
episodio qua davanti che ci hai un jobs
che arriva in 4 3 2
no però vedo che comunque allegro
sociale almeno almeno vi intrattenete in
qualche modo non solo con gli infarti o
c'è una porta per avis muten find kate
hanno preso ok ho preso una perla che
stava sulla maniglia vicenza smontiamo
alle maniglie delle porte senza motivo
la portiamo st pc facciamo tipo ingozzi
muletti organi giro con le bici comunque
non c'è più la tizia la fine è dettato
gioco tranquillo guarda ci possa
infilare la palla e ne manca una ho
capito ma volendo 2000 vazzano ti dice
dove mettere il costo che abbiamo appena
trovato qua dentro
ah ok ho capito e non ho letto scusa io
non leggo le cose ci infilo l'occhio
giustamente ma mai tipo un drone è tutto
chiaro adesso quindi
ha fatto grazie non è la prima volta che
uno youtube era firmato un suicidio
però la prima volta è finita male allora
anzi a posso pigliate l'occhio grazie
leo che mi serve a prima porta allora
ragazzi qua il suicidio dei cameraman lo
chiamiamo così se bisogno il suicidio
dei cameraman dai vabbè con cui finiamo
l'occhio di leo perché non dovresti
infilare l'occhio del tuo migliore amico
dentro una porta ma chi era suo
cameraman scusa per quello che sta
filmando all'inizio del gioco no ero io
voleva prima dall'inizio del gioco
cazzo guardi c'è un'altra porta eccola
permesso
entro qui perché un posto allegro se non
sarei entrato demonio che è successo si
chiese se la porta dietro
io dovrei giocare ragazzi dove giocare
agli horror con il volume molto più
basso qua c'è un armadio quando c'è un
armadio e perché sta per succedere
ecco l'unica roba brutta visto gioco che
secondo me non è fatta benissimo e che
mettono gli armadi prima quindi sai
quando succederà qualcosa perché c'è
l'armadio quindi se c'è l'arma ne sai
che ti devi nascondere sa che ci sarà
qualcosa sicuro tipo qua dietro salve
devi prendere il talismano cinese
mezzano nella porta principale nel
mentre che lei è lì dentro ok ci ricorda
vai aprire la porta a qualsiasi cosa
lirica non ho tranquilla non apro niente
no ma ti ringrazio per questo semplice
discorso che mi hai fatto
grazie non entrò è nel mentre che non
c'è ancora nessuno meno male mi di
funziona la torcia allora a quando
l'orologio segna sull'orologio segnale 8
le mettiamo le 8 vai vai ficcasse 8
eccoci
meraviglie ma tu ma the cooking
preparati per formino che quindi ho
messo l'orologio adesso teoricamente
sono scattate le otto sono scartate le 8
però effettivamente se io aspetto un
minuto e mezzo prima di uscire che
magari alle 8 precise succedono le cose
però alle 81 alle 8 e 1 si può uscire
800 no no comunque buongiorno tutto a
posto
va bene il mezzo della mezzanotte o per
questa aget la gatta ceco era mezzanotte
abbiamo fatto diventare l 8 sa
effettivamente cuore sono lei non lo
capisce tutto questo mi devo anche
fermare se mi devo nascondere perché la
tipa viene di qua tipo
non viene di qua perché non posso uscire
immagino
[Musica]
ho capito ma io dove vado sì sì sì
quello che hai detto sai che non ho ben
capito dove dovrete carso a posto a
posto a posto tranquilli non mi ha visto
non sa dove sono
non vi preoccupate tutto tranquillo ok
non ho capito dove dovrei ficcare
proprio di preciso il talismano però va
bè ragazzi non ho capito cosa devo fare
il tratto tra strada dei vini da idolo
chiude la porta a gli ho chiuso la porta
in faccia bene chiaro
bellissimo perché quello era il
tentativo di convincermi di aprire e far
la voce la bambina
it's quite inside neve sul teca look ok
io non avrei mai aperto la porta così
nonna a posto ho ammazzato la zia non so
come sia possibile visto che mi hanno
fatto il nome
bastava fare la spinta svenuta adesso
lodovini pia lava la faccia mi ammazza
beh colorito è a posto trovano re e che
intima senza amarezza ma [ __ ] sono
cagato addosso
ok vi ha detto le due colpi traduco
soleggiato perché io l'interpol l'abbia
abbiamo lasciato alla città
quindi se a me lasciando la città ci
siamo rimessi abbiamo ripreso la nostra
vita anche se lei era un po strana
perché rimasta terni quanto certificato
c'è scritto da quello che è successo è
terrorizzata non darei vigata all'inizio
poi ho ricevuto un messaggio strano da
lei e quindi voglio indagare che cosa
sta succedendo quindi loro sono sono
andati via si sono salvati tutto a posto
e parole ha iniziato a scrivere cose
strane
e infatti si vede urca pu
salve mi scusi come si permette perché
che aperto la porta va bene a data
storage minchia l'hard disk è co per
ragazzi di chiave cioè miglia nardi qua
c'è una stanza per gli hard disk ma dai
ma dai
michele giampiero usiamo drive
aggiornati the kid ma time ha veramente
ho preso un hard disk da piccard e
computer
l'altro non è neanche di quelli
plug'n'play cioè quelli che proprio devi
smontare il computer e ficcarselo dentro
vabbè comodo sto gioco è bellissimo c'è
una qualità nel dettaglio che spavento
ma neanche autras ragazzine anche
outlast sassi dettagli breve lo giuro su
dio ma guarda te c'è qualsiasi cosa sto
guardando la polaroid da attaccata al
muro
bellissimo 9 giu ragazzi su gioco è
pazzesco non sto scherzando
cioè clicchiamo la nel computer in
realtà dovresti smontarlo permettere che
però non fa niente facciamo finta che se
ne sa chi aveva potuto no devo andare io
poi ho chiesto capitoli dei forum
no veramente ac ma stai zitto che stai
per morire è invece dirk agate ancora
con il demonio porco senza insulti al
demonio che quando è tornato in via mi
piglia
ma perché quello è quello che ha fatto
un altro me lo devo subire io ma perché
dai ragazzi è veramente io dove il
personale sto cameramen ma è un dito ok
ho trovato un dito e mero press
bellissimo come non ho preso questo ma
dico sì ok tutto chiaro ma c'è qualcosa
come fascista roma sia aperta st porta
salve buongiorno
ma che bello qua tutto allegro è ficcato
dito qua va bene tutto questo casino
poi c'è una ics sul muro c'è un ep un
martello posso sfondare il muro che è
proprio quello che vuole
come tifi il permesso
[Musica]
max ragazzi delle droghe
ma se succede
tutto a posto carichiamolo su youtube è
quindi quindi ho vissuto in prima
persona questa cosa va bene ho capito se
ognuno qua ma bastava scontornato qui ma
non ci voglio credere dai ragazzi basta
ok ho schiacciato un tasto che era sul
tavolo però vedo che comunque poi tutto
come hanno lasciato quindi fan traffico
ai sfondato il muro no a posto si è
creato un varco bellissimo c'è è
successa una cosa veramente strana se ci
pensate però vabbè ho continuato nel
muro io non ha un benché minimo senso
tutto questo però contenti voi
mi scusi senta ma lei spaccia che cazzo
viaggi ma io non ho capito il senso di
andiamo avanti ragazzi tutta una perla
sto gioco tutta una perla ama cielo
aperto forse teoricamente potrei uscire
che non sarebbe male io lo stare dentro
né mai comunque pulirlo un edificio una
volta non fa male né che fai meno
horrors e sport cioè se è pulito e
sempre horrors anche anche se un
ospedale pulito e horror 6 buio di
puliteli e basta cioè che schifo di
tutto chiuso tra tutto che cade a pezzi
mattarello un martello accusare kong non
ci fai la pasta andiamo a tirarle mazzei
dal gong buongiorno
[Musica]
faccini casinò ai nino d'angelo ma
speriamo che vada tutto bene comunque
qua promette bene perfetto meno male che
non pensa se non lo dicevo pensa pesano
di ceo
tutto a posto corri un cristo madonna
c'è tra l'altro tra l'altro come entrato
lo sa solo lui aiuto aperto un corridoio
chilometrico arrivo ad hoc che schifo la
porta e non ci arrivo devo correre
l'altra ba che schifo allora garri bile
e qui chiuso qua se aperto
aiuto aiuto c'è una ragnatela aiuto
aiuto e c'è una ragnatela che faccio la
donna che schifo è un mix tra una
persona frutta e un ragno quindi due
cose che odio le persone brutte e i
ragni e dei ragazzi so che sono previsti
una persona va concluso qua perché io
sono bravo con cui dei momenti bijoux
proprio ci rivediamo al prosecuzione di
paranormal hk iscritti al canale spiace
la campanina prima la genesi di vita e
noi ci vediamo arma subito storia
[Musica]